[Musique]
bonjour gilbert eustache
oui bonjour monsieur le maire du diamant
vous êtes avec nous parce que vous avez
été le dernier président en exercice du
syndicat intercommunal du centre et du
sud le 6 mai qui n'existe plus mais dont
les comptes alimente toutes les
discussions
gilbert eustache pour faire court une
dette de plus de 20 millions auprès
d'entreprises un déficit de 14 millions
et un encours de dette de plus de 33
millions d'euros auprès des banques
comment en est on arrivé à cette
situation alors monsieur violent
permettez que je suis le dernier
président du 6 mai je voudrais rendre
hommage aussi au premier incident lui 6
qui a été monsieur alfonso joseph
puisque c'est une structure qui a été
créée en 1948 et aujourd'hui le succès
par les nouvelles lois note du 17 août
le site s'est amenée à disparaître vous
me posez des questions concernant la
situation du 6 aujourd'hui la situation
financière du 6 il faut savoir qu'en
arrivant 2008
il faut savoir quelle était la situation
du succès mon arrivée doc
moi j'ai été élu en 2008 et j'ai été
contacté par un certain nombre de
collègues maires pour que je reprenne le
6 qui était dans un désordre
inexplicable aujourd'hui donc il fallait
remettre de l'aude au niveau du cycle ça
crie ça va mettre de l'ordre et tai chi
fatale
je vais vous répondre monsieur bientôt
je vais je vous je vous assure qu'à mon
arrivée os x il y avait un climat
extrêmement délétère vous aviez un
certain nombre de problèmes au niveau du
personnel au niveau des structures et au
niveau des équipements
donc la situation du 6-1-1 2008 poser
problème il fallait que je me retrousse
les manches pour répondre à l'aspiration
de la population martiniquaise rivaux
tout de suite avril 2010 c'est parce que
le temps de la strate de nombreuses
questions et voir oui alors je peux vous
dire aujourd'hui que c'est pratiquement
100 millions qui ont été investis sur le
6 depuis mon arrivée et nous avions un
plan pluriannuel
de d'équipements pour faire en sorte que
nous puissions rattraper les équipements
qui sont nécessaires pour le
développement de la martinique dans
toutes les communes du 6 avril un avion
de dettes auprès des entreprises qui
aujourd'hui c'est le budget le budget
2011 du 6 nouveaux thèmes en eau potable
cité de l'eau de 29 millions l'eau
potable aux pelles ou looping en en
assainissement
nous avions prévu un budget de 44
millions à savoir 4 millions en 4
millions 4,1 en est en fonctionnement et
plus de 39 millions en investissements
dans ces 39 millions nous avions prévu
en subventions 26 millions 26 millions
compte nous devrions récupérer dans ses
26 millions il faut qu' il faut que
aujourd'hui ceux qui sont en charge du
cycle et de l'eau et de l'assainissement
puisse récupérer les subventions puisque
il faut payer
il faut payer les chefs d'entreprise
pour qu'ils vous donnent des
attestations de fin de travaux pour
aller pour pouvoir aller chercher
l'inspiration sauf que lorsqu'on regarde
ce qui pourrait rentrer avec ces
subventions convenait de le décrire ce
sera six millions et demi d'après ce que
disent les experts de l'expérience de la
suze ya quand même encore énormément de
millions qui ne vont jamais rentré alors
l'argent tous les plans de financement
et effet il suffit aujourd'hui d'avoir
la volonté pour aller chercher l'argent
est trouvé donc elle se passer des caps
nord font du oui alors je ne dis pas
qu'il faut d'humour et jeudi que les
élus en responsable aujourd'hui doit
savoir qu' il ya eu des travaux guère
d'effet sur toutes leurs communes
respectives reviendra tout les trucs les
communes respectives
aujourd'hui il s'agit de trouver un
financement aux élèves puisque si les
financements ne se présenter faute d'un
financement au lait qui vous permettront
de récupérer les subventions qui
souffrent présente les oeuvres se
joindre à notre voie vous paraissez
travers voir des chantiers ont été
lancés tout azimut aux ans d'arrêt à
ducos a rivière pilote européen travaux
nécessaires marché
vous redire m'en a dit zac et à
taupinière ce sont d'ailleurs les deux
seules chantier terminé dont le qui a
coûté le double ce qui avait été prévu 7
millions pour 10 à charritte et bien
ordonnée commence par ce noël
messieurs volts je peux vous dire que si
les travaux sont terminés diamant c'est
parce que le maire du diamant qui était
effectivement le processus et le
président du ciss le président du 6 il a
pu mettre en place
il a pu mettre en place le ce qu'on
appelle le patrimoine parce qu'il faut
trouver des terrains alors si si des
stations ne sont pas arrivées attire
aujourd'hui dans d'autres communes c'est
parce que pour d'autres communes il est
très difficile de trouver de trouver sur
d autres jeux solo qui n'ont pas su
faire alors je peux prendre le cadre de
punta les deux pontes et à lévis où ça
nous a pris beaucoup de temps au robert
pour conçu la station parce que nous ne
trouvions pas de terrains appropriés
pour mettre cette station au diamant
c'est allé très vite au diamant les
choses sont allées plus vite parce que
tout peut être parce que je suis le
maire mais je peux vous dire aussi que
dans d'autres communes c'est allé très
vite
alors que je peux vous dire que c'est
plus c'est allé très vite aux trois
ilets on avait des travaux à faire et je
peux vous assurer que ce sont des
travaux énormes de canalisations aussi
parce qu'on n'en parle pas mais c'est
faut savoir que os x régulièrement nous
avons des casses des casses importante
il faut répondre au jour le jour
monsieur alors le cap nord qui sort une
motion control non concernant ces
chiffres l'espace sud qui refuse de tout
à fait normal hâtif du cycle 1
il y a eu un rapport de la chambre
régionale oui conduit la main et puis il
ya ka demande si in fine c'est comme
deux pages exactement il ya quand même
certaines questions qui qui qui sont là
le lamentin et joseph et saint joseph je
faisais partie du 6 mai sont tombés
jusqu'en décembre 2014
kassam et au dc et un courrier des
services techniques fait état de
l'extension du réseau sur saint-joseph
qui ne faisaient plus partie du cycle
pour cent mille euros pour un seul
usager se sont dit qu'ils seraient là
non alors j'ai ce courrier alors je peux
vous assurer non non mais y'a pas de
problème
alors vous avez vous quand vous dites
c'est l'usagé ces jeux
on est très bien le problème c'est un
problème d'âge et les cupides j'en
arrive un os x mais vous pensez que je
n'ai pas le problème n'est pas né de mon
arrivée
vous aviez sur saint-joseph puisque
saint joseph est parti du succès à
l'époque un particulier qui ceux qui
venaient au nom de plusieurs familles il
faut pas déconner en particulier parce
qu'il ya quand même une dizaine de
familles qui étaient alimentaire parce
que c'était c'était un endroit où
l'alimentation été très difficile il
fallait mettre un accélérateur ce qu'on
appelle un accident nature donc il a
fallu investir parce que moi j'avais dis
je le répète c'est joseph ne faisait
plus partie du 6 là on a commencé on a
commencé les travaux et on a commencé
cette opération bien avant que ses
effets sont vous comprenez bien que
c'est josé ressort si on a comme si on a
prévu de faire du travail il faut aller
jusqu'au bout
je suis très heureux et très fier que
j'ai atteint j'ai été accompagné dans
cette opération
partout le comité du 6 à l'unanimité
bien contrat il ya un contrat qui était
passé ça s'est vraiment au centre de
beaucoup de discussions pour les états
lundi à l'espace sud est hier encore
arrivé à pilotes lors de cette réunion
pour faire le point concernant la
situation du sicm contrat a été passé en
avril 2015 entre le 6 mai et la société
martiniquaise des eaux est à notre porte
sur 12 ans alors que vous saviez que le
31 décembre 2015 il y aurait une
nouvelle gouvernance
pourquoi 12 ans vous pondent et tous
ceux qui viennent derrière alors je peux
vous assuré monsieur monsieur bio le ton
le contrat que j'ai occupées en 2008 en
arrivant il était de 12 ans vous savez
personne je ne fais qu assurer une
continuité ce qui me remplace
aujourd'hui ils peuvent remettre en
question le contrat lorsque j'avais un
avenant il faut que les auditeurs le
sache vous avez un avenant qui dit que
le 6 va payer les dettes de la cassait
les factures de la personne à l'asm avec
l'argent des contribuables duflot alors
sur ce point là ce seront là monsieur
viol tôt c'est le john o'dowd cesser le
6 le prestataire c'est l'asm
la relation se fait entre le 6
responsable de l'eau et de la production
de l'eau sur la tête son territoire et
la cacem qui est l'interlocuteur en face
l'asm ne sert d'intermédiaire
donc quand il s'agit de deux il ya des
contrats pour ça
oui vous avez dit vous avez j'avais un
point trois élus dans l'espace et
surtout vous avez un contrat qui a été
signé avec des clauses échec et c'est ce
qui est important aujourd'hui c'est que
le nouveau contrat dont vous parlez
c'est un contact a été 3 l'été et nous
allons faire en sorte qu' il y ait un
contrat extrêmement compréhensif direct
pour qu'il n'y ait pas d'interprétation
et c'est ce qui a causé beaucoup de
problèmes entre et se posent des
questions oui oui on peut se poser des
questions parce que ce geste je peux
vous dire aujourd'hui que lolo c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas la gestion des
ordures ménagères l'os et c'est quand
même des domaines extrêmement pointue
avec vous suiviez très bien je suis les
hauts fourneaux dial oui 7e forum corée
du sud alors qu'un abruti on n'a pas
beaucoup d'argent
est-ce qu'on a les moyens d'aller à
jusqu'en corée du sud pour suivre les
problématiques de l'autre ah ben il
fallait faire tout ça il fallait que je
ne me déplace je veux vous assurer que
dans tous les forums je suis allé et si
aujourd'hui on appuie havre des
financements de l'onema de les dieux
c'est parce que je ne puis j'ai pu me
déplacer et eci est lâché cioni salle de
frais de missions qui ont explosé alors
les frais de mission qui explose ici
parce que aujourd'hui nous avons pris le
pari de faire en sorte que le personnel
du 6 soit frau mais pourquoi nous
puissions à m'éviter la même un agent
qui était formée à 100000 euros aux
états unis non ça c'est vous c'est vous
qui le dites non non non non c'est vous
qui le dites très bon s'il a été formé à
5000 euros il s'agit dit-il
monsieur monsieur violent il nous a
permis de récupérer beaucoup plus que
cent mille euros
parce que je peux vous dire que les
formations que nous amplifions 6 fait
que aujourd'hui si le 6 à 1 sur 2
heureusement de 80% le mais un des
meilleurs taux de rendement de france il
vous l'avez dû le lire pour moi même et
bien c'est parce que quand nous
produisons 100 litres d'eau assez joseph
nous avons 80
l'it qui arrive à sainte anne au diamant
ou aux autres années donc c'est sûr les
performances et ce sont des équipements
qui ont été nécessaires pour que nous
puissions arriver à ce jeu c'est fini
c'est fini parce que nous sommes pris
par france info
merci on rappelle que vous avez été
président en exercice du 6 le dernier
président merci bonne journée
[Musique]